ふっｗ
あのマークイズっていう　家の近くにショッピングモールがあるんですよ
行きます！
みなさんコンビニとかお店とかレストランとかで
レシートっていうものをもらったことがあると思うんですけれども
今までもらってきたレシートで一番長いのってどれぐらいありますか
僕はそのちょっと人とは違うので２ｍぐらいのレシートをもらったことがあるんですけれども
２ｍ・・・てかレシートの世界記録あんのかな
レシートの長さ・・・
世界記録・・・
あったらやだなーなんかレシートって世界共通かん…
あ・・・あるあるあるまじであるじゃん！あれない！ないか
ないかもしれない！
あっ！待って！
レシートの世界記録がない！
ないよね、な、ない。ないよね
あ、ないな
ﾌｯ
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ
♪ゴン
ー＝ない＝－
という事はまあここで俺が今ここで
ケタ外れの長いレシートを作った瞬間
僕がもう…
世界記録保持者になるということですよね
そうですよね
というわけでレシートの長さを求めると
お店の人に迷惑がかかっちゃう
発音よかった　ごめん
長いレシートをもらうと思うとお店の人に迷惑がかかるので
自分でレジ買いました。
♪ピコピコピコ　ピコ♪
♪ガラーン　ガシャーン♪
はいという訳でこれ、バッチリ レシートも出ます。
それでも商品を打って、（カチャ♪
カチャカチャ♪ピコ♪
こうやってれば もうレシートが出てくるんですよ。
ビリビリィ（レシートを破る音
こういう感じでねぇ
レシートってどーやったら長くなるかというと、
商品が多ければ多いほど、
その品目が増えていく訳ですよ。
今だったら5種類物を買って、この長さになったんで、
数商品が多くなればいいという事は、
こうやって沢山商品を買えばいいんですよ。（ガチャガチャ♪
沢山商品買って、
こーやって金額打って、
お会計したら、
あ、お金足りない
ガチャカチャ♪
それで買うと、
ガチャッ！
うぃーん♪
ぴっぃぃ～～～～～～～♪
レシートが長くなる訳でございます。
意図的に僕が世界最大の長さのレシートを作ろうとしたときに、
注文する商品の数多くしまくって、
お会計すれば
多分、世界最大の長さのレシートが作れるんじゃねぇかという訳で、
ちょっくらギネスに挑んでみますわ。
ではいこう！
はい、という訳でやっていきましょう
中途半端な長さはもうダメなんで、
レシートの長さはとりあえず最大にしときたいんで、
ロールの長さは最大級に長くしたいところではある
OK。これで最大の長さになっております
はい。ではギネス記録に挑みましょう
とりあえず商品を注文しまくります
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ
商品をたのみまくって金額を上げていきましょう！！
ピピピ
ピピピピピピ
ピピピピピピピピピ
ピピピピピピピピピピピピ
ピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピ
ピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピ
ピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピ
ピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピピ
ﾋﾟｰｯ
は！？
Register buffer full
これ以上登録できません！？
え！え！え...
ﾋﾟ
やばい！このレジの限界が来てしまった。
Piiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
あ、無理か
101点ですね
101点注文したところで
レジが止まってしまいました
（ヘェックション！）
考えろ俺
レジを伸ばす方法を
お支払いのぉ
お金の数を以上に長くしたら・・・
0の桁によって、レシートが長くなる
例えば…今48480円でお会計したんですけども
48480円僕はお金出さなきゃいけないんですけども
そこを
1億円にしたら99951520円のおつりになるんで
そこでこの0とか色んな数字のケタで
レシートの長さをまた稼げると思うので
ちょっと金額を高めにお支払いしましょう
一、十、百、千、万
十万、百万、千万
一億、えっ十億
百億、千億
一兆、十兆、百兆、千兆
えっ！？無限じゃん！
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ
あっ
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ…
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ…
えっ
あ、無理だ多分
限界値の値まで来ましたね
多分でも十兆円くらいのお金出してると思うので
このままだと多分99999999951520円のおつりが返ってくるんで
レシートはかなり長くなるはずだ！
お会計！
ﾋﾟｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲ
ﾋﾟｯ
ｶﾞｺｰﾝ
あっ！きたきた！くるぞ！
えっ
ｳｨｨｨｨｨｨﾝ
ｶﾞｺｰﾝ
きた！！！
あれ？
もう1回やり直しです！
あああああああああ
ｶﾞｺｶﾞｺｶﾞｺ
きたぁ！
あとはお会計！
一、十、百、千、万
十万、百万、千万
一億、十億、百億
千億
一兆、十兆、百兆、千兆
あれ？
ﾋﾟｯﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ…
ﾋﾟｰｯ
無限大数いってんなこれ
お会計いこうと思います
これが　これがとりあえず俺が見せた中で一番長い
レシートになることを祈って
お会計！！
ﾋﾟｯ
あれ？お会計！
ﾋﾟｰｰｯ
いやいやだから
ｳｨｰｰｰﾝ
きた！きたきたきた！きたきた！
ほっほっほっ
あれ？
ｶﾞｺｰﾝ
うわっ！
商品の名前を長くすればいいんだな
商品の単価を999999円にして
というわけで色々設定をいじって
商品の名前を長くするのと
商品に金額自体のケタをかなり多くしました
999999円
商品の値段が文字数が少なすぎたので
なるべくそういう商品名とか
値段でケタを稼いで
より長いレシートを作れるか試してみようと思います
参る
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ
で、お支払いが
一、十、百、千、万
十万、百万、千万、一億、十億、百億…
ﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟﾋﾟ
ﾋﾟｰｯ
よし
お会計！
ｳｨｨｨｨｰﾝ
♪エンディング